hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith today in our best
picture close up the heartbreaking and
heartwarming true story of Philomena
touched moviegoers around the world
let's take a closer look I was gonna ask
if it be possible not to use my real
name when you write the story what about
amber lynn acid lovely net or what if
somebody had that yeah we're gonna have
to use your real name Philomena read an
article in The Guardian about this old
Irish woman looking for her son with the
journalist Martin Sixsmith I found
really really quite amazing story the
thing that really hooked me was to put
Martin Sixsmith who'd written the book
as a character in the narrative why
don't we do a story about this rather
middle-class oxford-educated government
spin doctor and this little old irish
lady Philomena and put her a Martin
together and make that the story so that
that's that's where we began I could see
Rob from the beginning that there was a
sort of romantic comedy on in there or a
filmer you know sort of odd couple film
whatever and then underneath it always
this ghastly business so that happened
50 years ago on the one hand does this
terrible tragedy and on the other hand
are these jokes so you're really doing
tragedy and comedy at the same time I
know I was found that interesting in a
nutshell I mean that the story is really
he ostensibly he thinks he's speaking
parts Pierce's of a journalistic knight
in shining armor and help this old lady
find her son so he thinks he's it will
give him some purpose or something to do
but really she teaches him a lot more
than he teaches her it is the most
extraordinary story and a true story and
somehow all the more poignant that she's
alive and I was able to meet her and
talk to her and she wants the story to
be told and it's a it's a remarkable
journey that she and Martin Sixsmith
made its film of optimism because the
two of them was so wonderful and they're
so touching and they're so fond of each
other I say given that it's a based on a
tragedy it's a remarkably cheerful film
I would hope it's uplifting I hope it
makes you quite angry I hope it would I
just hope it's really true to her and to
Martin Sixsmith really it's about the
triumph of the human spirit at the fact
that that after all that happened to
Philomena you know she came through it
and that she's positive and that there's
love in her heart still to see all the
backstage action on Oscars Sunday a
check out the Oscars backstage show on
the watch ABC app